the Joe Rogan experience it's hard for
us to understand what's really going on
because you know the news will show this
anecdotal story of a farmer who's upset
because there's you know he's losing
money because it Trump's tariffs and
then people go oh tariffs bad you know I
think it's a to have a really
comprehensive view of it it's gonna take
a lot of studying you're gonna have to
dive deep and really try to understand
the economics behind it all and I think
most people aren't willing to do that so
we get sort of sold a narrative on the
news I think the same thing happen with
like sort of so-called like industries
that were important on national security
like steel you know yeah those are
things that we want to be careful how
much we actually do outsource to
overseas because there might come a time
when we'll need those you know I mean
what happens if you globalized to the
point that China's producing all your
steel and then we have a war and where
it's all steel gonna come from it's just
so easy to be cut off he's really
worried about a hot war um
we're definitely in the in a cold war
right now in China yeah feels but you
know China does have military ambitions
I mean the their actions in the South
China Sea have shown that they do want
to be at least militarily strong they
haven't you know to their credit having
taken any they didn't go into Hong Kong
with tanks or anything right so no
bloodshed on that account yet but it's
one of those things also that in 2047
Hong Kong is going to return to China
fully anyway so they're willingly yeah
20:48 cuz the handover was only like
four or fifty years before this is just
the transition so mmm the long game
belongs to China and they know that you
know that this is not good it's not and
there's no hope in your eyes of China
eventually becoming what they hoped it
would be once capitalism was sort of
introduced if people got information if
there were ways to resist the
encroaching tyranny especially digital
tyranny right the in all forms so it's
not just mass surveillance all this AI
stuff there there
sort of like collecting people's uh like
facial scans yeah it's it's this is such
a dystopian nightmare it feels like it's
like a science fiction film frankly if I
don't know unless the revolution kind of
comes from within and enough people woke
up maybe it can be averted but otherwise
we're just gonna you know it's gonna be
headed to it's us we are bipolar worlds
where there's a new axis and a new
allies that sucks
that will suck that talks already it's
already you've seen like there you know
Russia has taken the set of China
Pakistan has taken the genocide of China
now so they're all there there is a you
know an alliance kind of forming you can
see it in you know what happened with
the UN passed this resolution condemning
China's treatment of the Uighur Muslims
in Sindh young yeah and the signatories
to that to that bill that UN bill was
basically United States New Zealand the
Europe a lot of European powers the
so-called you know like these are
countries that are often accused of
being Islamophobes because they won't
accept Muslim refugees or that many
Muslim refugees but you have Pakistan
and even some you know majority of the
Gulf countries siding with China
defending China on on their treatment
with with the Uighur Muslims in Sinjar
and it's one of those things that's just
like what how how is this happening
you know it doesn't make sense does
anybody have a roadmap of how they
expect all this to play out because it
seems that this this could be a real
problem in the future and most Americans
up until this whole the up until this
trade issue with the Trump
administration most Americans didn't
even think about China I don't know I
don't think I think Hong Kong was the I
think that kind of lit you know the
whole beer to seeing the hundreds of
thousands people in the streets every
day
weeks after months really young people -
yeah yeah I think that the thing has
kind of like to send them to police
brutality like protests against police
brutality now but it's still going on
they're still yeah and
now with the whole kernel virus you know
flaring up there it's it's highlighting
a lot of issues with the with the
Chinese government Taiwan is another
issue still there are the three T's you
can't really talk about in China now
kahneman Tibet Taiwan these are three
things that absolutely you know no-go
[Applause]